[Music]
all right as we continue hannity on the
ground in texas tonight we continue with
the former president donald trump
what a great crowd we don't have a lot
of time
but let's talk about your future plans
now i have a fun
[Music]
let me ask the crowd of everybody here
would you like to see the president
running in in 2024
you're not going to answer but i have to
ask
where are you in the process of or have
let me ask you this without giving the
answer what the answer is
have you made up your mind yes
yes
i think you got it right yeah
when you look you know what's funny
because i've known you 25 years
and i remember when you first talking
about running and we actually argued
remember we'd argue about certain things
in iraq and and
certain wars and everything and then you
became president and i remember when i
supported you i said
i i said he will govern as a
conservative and people didn't
understand
you really governed as conservative as
any president in the modern day
that is your core belief and actually
you have known me for a long time and my
views have never really changed i mean
i've
if you look at my views my views haven't
changed i felt this way about these
crazy endless wars where
we're losing so many wonderful young
beautiful people and
we're not fighting we're just sort of
there and
we don't do it you know we knocked out
isis you saw what i did during a short
period of time
over a period of a year and a half wiped
out the caliphate isis
wiped out the caliphate it was uh it was
getting worse and worse
but we got to bring our people back home
it's time 21 years in afghanistan
21 years and so uh we rebuilt our
military it was totally depleted it was
it was terrible we had jets that were 40
years old jet fighters that were 40
years old that they didn't make parts
for anymore you had to go to the desert
to get the parts
where they have what they call the
airplane graveyards
and we have now all brand new planes
brand new everything all made in the usa
now
we have to get we have to get ourselves
set we have to reorient
but uh the middle east has been a
disaster for this country we've spent
trillions and trillions of dollars we
got nothing
and the beauty was we didn't need their
oil anymore but now we're going to need
their oil again because
we're not going to be energy independent
we're not very long here we're right i
don't believe we are now and you're
you're when i left it was a dollar
eighty seven a gallon for a guess
and now it's three and a half it's
almost a dollar thirty more
just since joe's gotten to be president
let me ask you a question
because i would argue and i did argue on
air
often that you treated a whole other
standard for you
if you had sons that lied on a gun
permit through a gun in a dumpster
uh smoke crack got money from
ukraine with no experience kazakhstan no
experience
russia with no experience a hundred
thousand dollar shopping spree and a 1.5
billion dollar
deal with the bank of china with
military connections
i have a funny feeling that the media
would go after you
it would be unrelenting why does joe
biden get a pass
the democrats get a pass hillary clinton
got a pass the democrats get a pass you
look at a guy like bill barr they said
they're going to impeach him
and once they said they're going to
impeach him he became a whole he became
afraid he became afraid i said what's
wrong with you
he became scared they go after people
they go after him so
hard and so viciously and all of a
sudden
that's what happens not in all cases we
have some people that are incredible
but you have some people they get
brought over to the other side for fear
and we can't have that we have to we
have to fight
so strong look at me they go after me
with mueller with this one with that one
with impeachment one impeachment i call
it the impeachment oaks one
and two and all of this all nonsense
made up stuff
in fact they were the ones who were
guilty they come after me new york
radical left prosecutors come after me
you got to always fight you got to keep
fighting it's a disgusting thing
it's very important i guess they don't
call politics a
blood sport for for no reason
if you move forward you know how
difficult it is
but you seem ready to re-engage in in
that battle
and it's not that i want to the country
needs it we
we have to take care of the structure i
don't want to is this fun
fighting constantly fighting always i
mean
the country what we've done is so
important when i say
the greatest tax cuts now they want to
raise your taxes they want to double
your taxes and nobody and the
republicans in the senate
and the house but the republicans in the
senate
have to fight hard that the taxes don't
get up because that'll be terrible for
the country
i i've known you for years i've watched
you for years at trump tower i watched
you all the years you were in the white
house
you sleep maybe four hours a night four
and a half five
max um you never stop working
joe biden averages less than one
scheduled event a day
gets up at 9 30. he gets his warm milky
and sippy cup around 7 p.m
if he's good he gets a night night story
now
in all seriousness we saw what happened
at the g7
where he just was paralyzed
you see what happens how he struggles to
communicate
i asked you and you kind of punted the
last time you were on
do you see a cognitive decline in joe
biden and what does that mean to america
well let me say it a little bit
differently
he is surrounded by vicious people that
are very smart
but they don't stand for the values that
the people in this room stand for
these are very smart people i mean he
didn't campaign against me he didn't
debate well he didn't make good speeches
he's hid in the basement
i watched him on the state of the union
get up and speak
and it was terrible it was i don't want
to go into that but it was terrible it
was a terrible
and i thought he was going to get killed
and i had to watch your
competition just to see what they were
saying now fdr was a great speaker
you remember some of the speeches he
made were incredible
and the only thing you have to fear is
fear itself with that beautiful
sure they compared him to fdr
okay now the good news is they've lost
you should have
been watching hannity that was not
always happening no i know i watched
that well that one i could have
predicted
yeah but no but look there was nothing
good it was embarrassing
and they were comparing him to fdr
now it was so embarrassing to watch that
i couldn't believe it i was surprised i
watched specifically because i said he's
going to get killed
he didn't get killed they said great and
nancy was sitting behind him with the
single biggest mask i've ever seen
that was a that was a large it covered
her entire face i've never seen anything
like it
no i've never seen anything like it i've
got to write
she didn't rip up his speech either like
she did with you rip
mr president thank you very much